welcome to this video new tactics
trainer video let's see let's see we
have 2000 yeah let's let's start with
that it's 2000 rated problems him and
we'd start the first position you're
playing a black it looks like we should
try to get the White King right where is
the mate has there checkmate somewhere
f6 looks like it's good yeah f6 King g5
v check Queen King g4 Bishop e6 check
King h4 Luke s remade this looks this
looks quite good g5 he has to go to g4
give the check and here we are meeting
him yeah that's nice
just a sequence of well time checks gets
the White King to the meeting position
at the edge of the board ok nice start
ah huh this position we had again and
had earlier in the earlier video 95 is a
solution and Knight f3 we need a piece
ok I'm just skipping to the next one ok
let's see
Wow what kind of position is that that
looks it looks really weird so we are
what the piece down and we are taking
the King King is completely open on D -
yeah okay we can think about just just
capturing of course or various various
checks but the chicks they don't like
like they'll eat with that much like a
queen
well like Queen g5 check weight of it is
a double the check
it's just double the check on the bishop
and the king and if we win the piece we
will win the game yeah we have a ton of
pawns so why isn't Queen g5 not winning
probably just winning what else
King and we just take the bishop yeah
that's it's really it's a case where it
looks terribly complicated but you just
take this piece and now you know we're
winning it looks like the first thing I
have that is the most there must be made
or what but here we are two pawns up and
we still have an attack mmm so that's
it's a very simple solution to this okay
yeah this this we also had before the
solution is Bishop e4 check and yeah
first is check
this check and mate
okay let's go to the next one
okay wow this looks like there should be
should be some some attack coming here
95 is the first move that you want to
consider
yeah it's their direct direct made so
Nyjah 5 threatening Queen age 7 mate and
he has to take it g6 this Bishop b2 and
black is getting totally killed so he
has to take it and then Queen g6 looks
good
intending queen h5 mate yeah that's very
strong if he goes rook f6 to block to
block on h6 we go Queen h5 check Luke h6
create check and that's it King f7
Bishop g8 check King back bishop f7 yeah
this is the mate
so now g5 is going to going to go to win
yeah and now we can not the check here
it does not make any sense he can block
but as I originally had thought that
this this is a win okay miss desperado
ink the bishop but white is winning of
course mm how exactly king age 7 don't
see a series of checks but yeah okay you
can you can play Bishop f5 check g6
Bishop g2 Bishop b2 or something like
that
oh it's the series of checks making em I
of course we can get Bishop GHA King G
628 okay
so the the next one oh wow this looks
this looks very very trickier for my to
survive yeah it's it's a typical case
where we want to check the most forcing
moves Black has a huge tech obviously
and we need to check most violent stuff
first and here the most violent move is
this and it wins it's a meter
check again
yeah kingi one row gauge one mate and
this is also made so violent moves first
checks the very forcing moves first very
often those the best ones the aggressive
forcing moves he had led to and direct
checkmate huge attacking position for
black okay let's look at the next one
haha so black has taken on f3 so I
wonder what is the problem
so look t6 check King to the e-file
going to check on if I F is going to the
F fire and then we're taking the rook
isn't this just winning I don't see I
don't see why not
we can check briefly the ropes e7 check
Kimi ed check no there's no win so we're
just going to win the rook and that's it
yeah
king of seven king of free end and
resins we just won rook okay the next
one
this looks this looks defense not really
so and again yeah we have lots of
attacking pieces and we want to check
the the most forcing violent who's first
here in fact not really I was thinking
that you could argue about the right
move owner but okay queen g6 it's really
possible king takes this route g3 mate
yeah it's funny funny made yeah I was
briefly thinking if you pull up the
Nellis is bordered that you could also
take on a fire first because we have
Queen g6 is the same mate but after
Bishop f5 like theoretically speaking
can take on f6 and sort of try to hold
on I believe so Queen g6 is probably the
the best best way to go
if he goes to h8 by the way then we're
going to take on f5 and Queen h6 is this
is deadly is this mattering really yeah
maybe rook chicks even Queen h6 isn't
made anyway enter up like like ants no
move yeah Queen here six is coming okay
the next one this looks dramatic really
what do we want you yeah ideally rupee
one mate yeah this is a funny situation
the rook or Queen only one is a
checkmate and if we see that yeah we
probably seek retake c4 bang yeah 90 X
that was rookie one mate and here we
just
are tons of material of yeah so if we
want to look at it again c4 here was
played and now Queen c4 the big point is
that this is a funny mate
yeah the the study of Czech mating
patterns and and motifs really helps
here the Queen on g2 is really a very
much obstructing obstructing White's
King so Queen c4 is very strong white
also has no alternative if he goes King
here to e2 there's probably more than
one way to go but this is one of them
you know at the end netting in exchange
maybe maybe there's something something
even something even quicker but this is
definitely enough okay next one mmm-hmm
interesting
oh no wait wait just just for I was I
was I'm really irritated sometimes
because it looks it looks like there are
multiple ways to do it but okay there
are some things that are not working if
we start with that like weensy five
check queen takes rook takes 96 loops
and we've plundered the rook but about
loop takes at five now with the check
looks looks very very very very
problematic after that there is only
king g1 and Queenie to what is the
defense 96 check King g6 and and resins
I guess I don't see a defense to that
the maid on g2 s is quite quite
something
I don't see a defense I'm sorry I mean
isn't this just winning and now Queenie
- not Queenie for her because of 9066
with a mega fork but this is just a
winner
96 King g6 white person doesn't have a
check and that's it okay I'll take it
okay so it just needed to be precise
with Queenie to not blundering into
Queenie form and get a blundering
Queenie for allowing the fork okay so
the next problem okay oops so we had
tons of material down in this position I
see so it's this just is it enough
yeah I guess a draw is the the thing
that we want here I don't really believe
that black black and made oh wait maybe
we can made
hmm I don't don't see how thou whom
interesting writer threatening Queen
takes d5 that that's important so we
don't we cannot play let's take 95
intending Queenie of three ends and
stuff like that he can take d5 with a
check so this is definitely not going to
work if we just want to draw we have
Queenie too I guess
Queenie to King takes Queen x5 checking
G to Queenie to back kingi one Queen III
check this is such as the total but this
is a perpetual just like that so we have
a draw but can we win it's their way to
win
it's hard to believe really because we
don't movie simply out of out of bullets
you know it's a big big don't have any
pieces to do to get to and I think we I
think we just just make the draw here I
don't I don't really see anything else
Knight f4 is probably not a draw but but
Queen e2 is and I don't see how to I
know we need to draw it everything else
would be really weird or is there some
miracle move there isn't it is just
wrong it's just wrong
yeah of course if you have a draw in
hand it's a it's a convenient situation
you know that you you can play this this
drawing line all the time
and you should also in a practical game
always use the the time that you have to
check if there is more often there is
more yeah the sweet times there are
there are ideas getting some some sort
of final peace until the attack yeah
when you not need to give the perpetual
and can enforce improve your attack but
here there is nothing to do we don't
have any pieces that we can bring to the
the battle and we need to we need to
make the draw here okay let's check out
the next position again this is a
position that we had to be formed
so let's it was this solution and now
black gives back back
okay I don't want to do this
repeating positions or do do much invest
much time on them okay so what is this
interesting
oh that's really a funny situation yeah
it says let me check this this might be
some sort of almost a positional wind in
a way with neither three yeah if we
consider Knight f3 what is white smooth
it's almost a super Swan
almost because if white what's white
students qg2 is 91 oops
if you move the rock away from the D
file you just promote rookie 3d won't we
figure was rook somewhere else like d5
we play Knight deform and then the pawn
promotes so he has to play pawn moves
and once he is out of pawn move isn't
tzuke's one I can also advance the King
King @ g5f 44 and so on so 93 wins I
mean no doubt about that yeah and I do
you wanna hear this is this is not that
difficult and we have the piece it's
it's really nice it's really nice it's a
kind of a yeah like I said like a
positional wind it's almost fun we get
it back on the analysis board after 93
he has no move if he does something like
that on the defy we go here and then we
promote and what what can you do we can
we can play upon like let's say it's
something like that and I'm just
advancing with the King is the simplest
solution yeah here here yeah yeah and
something like this is a total hook
swung chain g2 again that's 91 check
check and here some somewhere somewhere
around here
he's he's out of out of moves look
somewhere 94 and resigns yeah quite nice
a totally dominating
by the night and them and the porn okay
so we have this rook cornered funny
that's really funny
do we I'm slightly irritated because
isn't this winning with luck normal
means like Bishop age five and and black
is just toast
I really wonder his rook is strapped his
rocket strapped so we should should win
this pretty easily but okay maybe there
is more to it maybe there's more to it
hmm yet
you know Bishop h5 is just a winning I
mean Bishop h5 king f4 Knight f5 and we
win this piece and at the end we will
win then game there is absolutely no
question there it's there some some
weird we had to draw and this is no 1800
2000 problem
there's some we are drawing positions
with a knight up but probably
overthinking this terribly King is sixth
of course also possible but then this
rook h1 that they don't then I can take
f6 I'm wondering I mean I think this is
this should be winning right and now we
just need to be of course not 97
allowing new gauge 5 but we can do
somewhere else is it mattering very much
where we go yeah if we go here we will
win the f1 definitely Knight f6 and g5
coming up
huh
yeah this wasn't so difficult but I was
I was irritated nevertheless it's just
not really a tactical thing in a way it
is something that can be calculated but
if we go back to the original position
this is just also I mean his route gets
trapped we will just win the rook and
this is not really a for me a tactic
because we will just see that we will
win this by by normal means they are
winning f6 and then winning the trap
look so nothing nothing very exciting
here however there are some things that
that probably are useful to know if we
look at the analysis port here and we
continue this line yeah this is a bit
too complicated there are some weird
drawing positions where her briefly was
concerned for example if we look at this
we look at this position yeah and here
white has a pawn on d5 that's good
because let's say the pawn would be on
h6 in this position yeah then this
position is a draw it's a very real it's
a drawing position but it's very useful
to know that the white cannot win here
with the pawn on h6 so we at the
fortress situation with the King in the
corner you will all you always have
stalemate defenses so funny situation
but probably not nothing that can happen
out of this out of this problem this
position okay next one mmm
this looks uglier so how are we going to
do this
it's one of those cases where you sort
of automatically and look at all kinds
of checks and Knight f3 and 92 when
whatever and well what does he doing
here after that absolutely nothing it's
very easy but you sometimes are too too
much focused on nonviolent moves yeah
checks and so on and you just threaten
yeah and it's over yeah not much to look
at just one of those things where it's
so simple that you sometimes overlook it
okay next one
ohhohh again we have a brave wandering
king okay so yeah it looks like we
should really have a medium but where is
it where is it exactly the the most
obvious move he has rook takes his six
at least to my mind and then Queen takes
d5 but I'm not sure that I'm seeing a
mate already
hmm I'm not seeing a maid funny enough
maybe with Bishop b1 check additional
name
it looks terrible really gadget did you
come this is winning an rooks is six
Queenie five chick King g6 yeah but how
exactly are we going to win
Queen g7 Lee can always go to age five
check here on age seven hmm okay okay
before we focus too much on that maybe
maybe there is a far far simpler
solution but rook F 1 kg 7 I'm not sure
yeah Luke c6 is definitely very forcing
but I don't see a maid I'm sorry I mean
probably I'm just totally blind as you
know but I don't see it
look f1 King g7 is this winning we are
look down now already what else is there
check on h6
Wow Wow yeah yeah and it's a it's also
there's also Bishop takes e5
it's a that shouldn't be a
underestimated okay um here it's a tier
Bishop T so Queen here is actually Queen
takes I think Kareem takes 26 a king g6
yeah and now I think we need to insert
check on me one the direct check on g7
after King h5 I don't I wait a cavity
for actually G form it should have six
check King a3 Wow
or is there some some other way to win
this
yeah I should have calculated this
beforehand man getting lazy at the end
of the video
how do i actually win here I think it
should be this check right this is like
matter of logic what I would have tried
here but not a matter of calculation so
how is this a maid know exactly if we
look at this at the end analysis board
so after this check the only asking edge
six and now a screen f4 yeah probably
Queen g7 King age five I'm not so sure
about what or is it is it a meteor as
well somehow
I guess it's also made it's too much on
the king too much on the king but I
really I really was too is it to
calculate it it's been a really long day
okay so I at the end of funny
King Hunt in the middle of the board but
I really think I should close the video
enter and take a break yeah
I really wasn't seeing straight at the
end okay thanks for watching